It is hard to believe that the waste in this landfill...
...could be used to make items like garbage cans and chairs,...
...but an Israeli company called UBQ is doing just that and has patented a process...
...to convert household trash into a reusable composite material.
So what you're looking at here might look like garbage,...
...but what we do is we convert it, so we can convert it into a chair, a table,...
...a trash can, a flower pot.
The company uses trash that is not recycled.
It involves all your food leftovers, the banana peels,...
...the chicken bones and the hamburger.
The dirty plastics, the dirty cartons, the dirty papers,...
...everything is in this material.
We have dried it.
We have grounded it...
...and we have converted it with a revolutionary patented technology.
The garbage is ground down and made into pellets...
...that other companies can use to produce the composite items.
They can actually use the equipment they have,...
...make the products that they already make,...
...only that now they'll be using UBQ material instead of plastic.
UBQ hopes its innovation will help revolutionize waste management worldwide.
Debra Black, VOA News.